okay look don't get on my case about
fact I'm not my usual 11th doctor get up
I just didn't feel like busting it out
today and besides some crazy woman blew
up my Fez
[Applause]
[Music]
all right everyone series 5 done and
dusted for our revisit and that means
it's time to rank v's now despite the
fact that I did end up doing one of the
two partners to separate reviews I don't
normally do that we're going back to
business as usual here for the actual
ranking which means that we have tend to
do because I'm counting two parters as
one story here we go
ranking series 5 from the lowest to the
highest
starting win number 10 the vampires of
Venice which honestly if this is the
worst of Scott it's not that bad it's
not terrible I just have almost no
highlights to give this thing it's got
really good music in it that's about all
I've got on this one it doesn't really
have anything that that is the oh well
it's got that it's got a couple of cute
lines but the monsters aren't a great
design the consistency of how they the
they even behave and react to things
like sunlight is it's not there cuz it
varies from instance to instance the
whole mommy's boy thing didn't really
work for me what is where things are
with Amy and Rory's relationship it's a
necessary step for towards you know them
getting everything sorted out but it's
it's a it's a weird awkward step that I
don't really enjoy and just there isn't
a lot for me in this one moving up there
from to number 9 victory of the Daleks
now this is an episode that has some
stuff I like but it is counterbalanced
by stuff that doesn't really work so
first of all if you missed my review of
the thing proper I do in fact like the
new paradigm Daleks I think the
visualization maybe a little garish in
the coloring but I think the concept is
solid the execution and how they were
brought in maybe not the best but I like
the fact that the Daleks basically won
this time I like the doctors
interactions with them Amy's good the
Winston Churchill character is good but
then there's the whole artificial the
you know Android guy who fake invented
them and he's a bomb and then he's not a
bomb because he feels loved and and
there's spitfires and spaces and
yeah it the pieces don't quite fit
together and the ones that aren't that
good do drag down the rest but there is
at least highlights in this one which is
more than I could say for vampires of
Venice next up number eight hungry earth
and cold blood reintroduction of the
Silurians into Doctor Who and that's
solid it's not great it's not bad it's
just solid the performances are probably
the best thing here and some of the
guest characters Nasreen is especially
really good um but the Silurians are
well performed and executed the doctors
on his game for this one there's a
couple of dumb lapses that characters
have to basically facilitate the plot
moving on but also at the loss of Rory
and Amy's acting of that both the the
loss the pain of it and then forgetting
it really well done so again a little
bit like victory of the Daleks some high
some lows the lows aren't as low as they
were in that one so that's why this one
gets a slightly higher position number
seven the beast below not really
anything wrong with this one
but I do still contend that this came
too soon in the season for what it tries
to do in terms of you know really
bringing into question whether the
doctors gonna keep Amy around that has
no weight and like him getting so ticked
off at her doesn't have weight because
they haven't been together long enough
and the overall concepts this some of
the stuff is thrown in here kind of
haphazardly in terms of you know the
smilers they look cool but they don't
really do much the space whale is just
it's a concept that might just be a
little too weird for the political
points that are being made that said the
political points are actually kind of
interesting as far as what if people
could make the selfish choice and then
not have to live with the consequences
which is basically the system that gets
set up I think there are some
interesting commentary some interesting
concepts going on there and I do think
the performances are are all really good
now so like Liz 10 I kind of wish they'd
figured out more to do with her in later
episodes and bring her back but she was
fun next up number 6 the Pandorica opens
in the big bang now those reviews went
up fairly recently I really like the
door opens I really don't like the Big
Bang and between the two of those things
it lands here
so without reiterating every single
point the Pandorica opens it was a
really cool setup or really neat concept
the bringing together of all the enemies
the idea of locking up the doctor and it
just left things in such a state how
could we possibly get out of this and
then the Big Bang was so focused on
tying up all the logistical loose ends
it really doesn't work emotionally as a
story until the last eight minutes those
last eight minutes or so are quite solid
but prior to that the tone is all our
place and even the logistical solutions
aren't as clever as they think they are
it's just a whole lot of things of
convenience things are there until the
plot doesn't need them anymore then they
just get dropped like little Amelia hey
oh wow
all right halfway mark number five the
lodger
it's basically doctor who is a live-in
sitcom and I enjoy it I find it fun
it's fluff there isn't a heck of a lot
to it there's not a lot of meat on the
bones of this thing but it's a tasty
little treat of us of an episode as far
as I'm concerned I do like James Corden
I find him quite endearing even though I
don't like a lot of the stuff he just he
decides to put himself in he himself is
usually a welcome presence for me he's
got really good chemistry with Matt
Smith there's some cool imagery as far
as the you know the the image is used to
lure people up to try and get them to
pilot the thing I learned thanks to my
commenters that Matt Smith is actually
that good at football so that was that
mean it's cool it's fun it's light but I
enjoy it number four time of the angels
and flesh and stone' okay we're getting
is some good stuff here and yes I have
mine it picks about this in terms of how
the Angels behave and how they're used
and there are some things in some steps
that just undercut the tension but when
the thing isn't undercutting its own
tension or breaking its own rules then
it is really good and very effective the
image of the angel moving was really
cool and really effective and just the
rising tension in some of the scenes was
terrific good
supporting cast on this one too it's
nice to have river back father Octavian
was great i I do appreciate how it
connects back to the Big Bang if you are
paying attention on to rewatch that's
all very cool it's good stuff and I do I
do like the things that are good in this
quite a bit and there is definitely more
good than bad in this two-parter number
three the eleventh hour oh what a kick
off to this season this thing had it
really kicked into high gear
it immediately Matt Smith on top of
exactly how he was going to portray the
doctor it mmediately and he was great
with young Amelia and even better with
adult Amy Matt Smith and Karen Gillan
have such great performance chemistry
between the two of them Rory getting
introduced was a lot of fun and just so
much of how it just bounces around and
it keeps a decent pace and the doctor
his we're basically having to keep up
with his mind scrambling to put together
what's going on but he hasn't quite got
everything going yet it's it's really
good it's really little paced it's the
perfect introduction to this doctor I it
is I think by far the best first episode
you know introducing the doctor
definitely with the modern era and it
just does everything is trying you so
well like there's a couple of tiny
nitpick execution things that I would
tweak if I were to if I had the power to
go back and do it but like this is solid
stuff
number two Amy's choice I've always
loved this one but going back and re
watching it with the level of
appreciation that I have for Rory and
Amy's relationship I really like this
one a lot and I've always liked it
viscerally for the dream Lord because
Toby gentlemen says so good
and this is so much fun but the way this
pushes Amy and to realize you know what
she really wants and when the chips are
down what choice she's gonna make and
that really does pay dividends not only
later on but it's important to the
progression of her relationship with
Rory overall as well as her dynamic with
the doctor because her dynamic what the
doctor is informed by the fact that she
knows at the
end of the day she's gonna choose one
she's going to choose Rory and firmly
establishing that I think was a really
good call on the story they used to do
it is really effective and really fun
and finally number one in my opinion the
best episode of series 5 of Doctor Who
Vincent and the doctor
I don't know what there is for me to say
about this it is a gorgeously crafted
brilliantly thought-out and constructed
examination of depression for someone
suffering it and for the people who care
about him and can only do so much to
help it is a terrific celebration of the
importance of a life while acknowledging
that depression is a battle that some
people are going to lose no matter what
but that doesn't make it not worth it
to be with them to care about them and
to head to their pile of good things
this is a singular piece of work it is
it is important beyond even the scope of
Doctor Who it is an important artifact
in representation of depression a
realistic look at it I get a lot out of
Doctor Who I would not have expected
something like this from this show as
much as I loved it and I'm really
wonderfully touched that my favorite
show to do this that's why it's my
number one pick how would you rank the
episodes of series 5 of Doctor Who
whatever your ranking is drop something
down in the comments let's talk about a
bunch of stuff to do down there as well
because there's buttons links you can
support me on patreon greatly appreciate
it helps me cover my bills plus in
addition to that you know the like the
SUBSCRIBE all those things help boost me
in the eyes of the algorithm we must
appease it lest it wiped me off the face
of the earth so please help me out click
on things buttons comment or don't
I appreciate it but I'm not gonna tell
you what to do because at the end of the
day you're the council I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]